I guess Patrick this first question
would be for you there's a lot of
nationalities on display here so I was
kind of curious how did you decide on
making Tobias an American pilot why
focus on a flight from Berlin to Paris
was there certain meaning behind those
choices yeah of course you know this is
an international thing we all have to
deal with and I want to make it an
international film this is not based in
one nationality this is about Europe
this is about America is about how we
all how everything is connected this
globalized world and and you know that
was of course a choice I made make it
international you know the national cost
international throne because this is
something so I know that you bought a
plane to shoot this movie and Joe you
obviously have to learn a good deal of
pilot jargon so between the attention to
detail in both respects do you guys see
any specific tells now when you're
watching other movies that involve
airplanes where you're thinking to
yourself you know that's not authentic
to real life now of course every
airplane movie you know and every films
where when they shoot inside of an
airplane and shoot inside of the cockpit
just how did they do it what works for
me and what doesn't you know and I try
to create takeoff experiences I saw they
did and you know to myself and of course
I see it but I see a barrier sometimes a
lot of like this Joe is there any
seemingly silly question you had about
the day-to-day of being a pilot that you
know you found out what the answer was
and you kind of couldn't believe it well
this movie was so much about the realism
and we definitely wanted to get all the
technical details of the aviation and
everything right and it helped a lot
that
the actor playing the captain of the
plane was a real pilot Carlo great actor
but also a pilot who flew with Danza
Airlines for many years but but the big
challenge with this movie really wasn't
any of those technical details that the
challenge of this movie was the way that
Patrick shoots movies is completely
different than how I've ever shot a
movie before and and it's it's not to do
with the technical details it's to do
with the emotions he is so focused on
letting the actors fully immerse
themselves in the reality of their
characters and their experiences he he
actually is all about stripping away as
much of the technical process of
filmmaking as possible to leave room to
just let the camera roll and let the
actors be and you know depart from the
script and and just be real and that was
incredibly intense really new for me and
you know that that's the experience I
was looking for you know III took a
couple years off acting when I had kids
and I knew that when I came back I
wanted to find something that would
really challenge me and inspire me as an
actor and and I found it here